[Music]
perfect welcome back to dirty arty this
is chapter 22 zero
hello Jake welcome back dude
oh god I forgot on when Jake was away on
vacation he somehow fell into a coma and
now he's only speaking oh I haven't been
able to get through to Jake he is
officially dirty arty he's going for
full immersion and he wants to take he's
Jake wants to take it one step further
and he wants to play as dirty arty ooh
first person I'm sorry dirty arty is
here with us today Jake is not here
that's right we're playing Red Dead
Redemption two as dirty already in first
person and I'm I'm gonna be the voice
inside dirty Artie's head and we're
gonna shut up oh sorry sir I'm gonna do
my best to give you ideas like I think
we should rob a train yeah you do don't
you dirty word Franco from yeah let's go
find that train we're gonna harm Arturo
oh nice look at that resolution on that
blade Oh No
Oh No how you feeling today dirty
already is this is this more challenging
and first-person Oh oh man oh nice shot
oh yeah Oh what are you gonna do with
your friend oh he's got his underwear on
the outside of his pants what you're
looking for so do oh no are you okay
whoa Oh your friend your friend fell off
Oh little wake-up call is that your way
of shooting your horse Steve here
wait oh God oh oh oh here's the train
tracks
oh no I'm not do your plot to rob a
train hmm
yeah what's what's your plan of attack
here Artie jump on board jump on board
steal everything [ __ ]
that's it Oh camp here some bandits oh
dang Nate up got him
Oh your dad your dad oh damn oh he's
missing a hand there wow what a view I
mean what a view there you go nice and
comfy you gonna help me Rob train mm-hmm
I don't even know what awful is what is
it I have no idea
it's like organs and trails animal
organs
there's Burford for me like my favorite
food it's like waste material I for some
reason was thinking it was more like and
like an oatmeal
that's gross just lazing about huh don't
care what you think on a second I'm
gonna Rob all right
nice no no one saw that cool that's the
first crime I've gotten away with
normally there's a person hiding in like
the goddamn bush across the field that
sees me and starts running for them they
have no idea what's coming from oh no
don't get hit by the train don't get hit
by the train
oh my god there goes our friend oh I got
up though train wearing the crow hat -
yes don't like you do you where you
escape from you kiss your mother with
that mouth
Oh
all your money now don't make me as I
[Music]
guess this guard over here didn't hear a
thing well yes my favorite got him you
think mm-hmm
oh shoot hi
yeah oh I don't have anymore when's this
train gonna get going oh you gotta hurry
he's gonna get spooked was that hammer
yet cuz that was him right oh my god I
can't catch up to it
yo I'm sorry this train is looking
that's cuz I'm coming for it
conductors look at his rearview mirrors
sees this oh [ __ ] it all nice
hell yeah oh yeah crouched couch couch
technology yeah it's stealthy on this
guy oh it stopped how later is it
stopping us stop
who reported that crime hi Amy
you'll be dead don't want just walk into
the crowd or just do it
well this guy's plan just to talk you
down
[Music]
oh not like this damn it shut the hell
up
perfect yes I was hoping you were gonna
do this oh my god
[Music]
they went through the gears guess what a
train conductor now dirty already good
morning here comes our boy Oh Oh what is
happening I didn't move I'm liking this
first person beans mm-hmm I'm not liking
first person anything else though yep
well I feel like we've exhausted the
Train oh yeah I think so too what if we
go to a bar and getting some first
person first person fights first with
some first person friends
[Music]
I'm at your camp
anyone home hopefully comes back what
the [ __ ]
sleep until tomorrow evening these guys
arm around you sleeping someone kept to
Fargo for me weird give me a ticket
anywhere can we check it no ticket
[Music]
they're having a private conversation
continue continue I hate that guy so
much they're having a private
conversation
oh really you know that dub I was like a
dirty already didn't actually stop the
thing you just shot the guy you said
that six times in the head
that works for me don't I know you from
punching all those cows and kids so just
be careful what you want around these
parts you here what are you failed
lawman I reckon we'd be funnier with a
set of broken teeth oh you're done
[Music]
this guy just got infernally I'll check
you all on Oh
[Music]
[Music]
said persuasion Fighting's kind of cool
yeah oh hey you guys shot first
I know Wow intense Oh
honestly with the precision their
decision there I feel like all the other
bullets would just go white through like
one after the other like through his
head but his head explodes
oh [ __ ]
that was cool I missed an arm but due to
this guy - while you're at that I got
drink this potion don't you believe in
magic one that was so badass the body
look at the body
oh man yeah try to ID this guy now
give him a friend to drink I think you
need your lunch just yeah just just pour
the whiskey down his neck movin fast I
need a doctor
my friend that feels too well oh he's
back like on the bartender came back
making like alright I could probably
like finish out the night already go
Arius found you
yeah yeah that's all too much in first
person yeah oh hello it is over
I meant to hit more than just his head
I like how you did the head first oh
yeah I should I do the head last huh
yeah I tried to do the head last gonna
keep down in these tonics the object of
the game is to shoot him in the head
while he's in mid-air but I gotta get
all the all he's still got an arm though
I think I mean even out of the book stop
shooting at me I'm checking the body
that is really gross and now it's time
for show us your arty where you guys
send in your own variations and
interpretations of dirty arty through
art or in-game footage first up here we
have B in the corner or bear tick the
gem that's awesome yeah this is great I
love the I don't know just the style
like his hands that are bloodied but
they're also like like the cartoon
mitten sort of things mm-hmm it's very
good very good love it also he's got a
bullet hole like through his chest yeah
nice little touch and some slime on the
bottom of his jacket oh this one was a
while ago but this was really good this
was a while ago
and this is done by my girlfriend
Whitney Lynn thank you so much who
finally finished read that right she
finally did she can get caught up
totally yeah now she can actually watch
some of these episodes but yeah I love
it
it's awesome very awesome this one I
like this a lot
dope sketch oh man I like the way the
barrel is done like the perspective of
like he's got a can of beef handful of
beans there too yeah I love the I like
the like kind of the style they've been
firing looks like it's sending off some
yeah some I guess sparks looks great it
almost looks like it's from like
Arthur's Journal like
right like I feel like you go to picture
myself that's what he draw it as when in
reality he looks way more disgusting
than that show portrait this one oh wow
have a little snack huh
yeah dude gamer or at dude flame
underscore one came across some pigs
well he probably put that body there
[Laughter]
yeah I think I think that's exactly what
happened we got a little knife in the
belly there and the pigs pigs be hungry
okay I don't know I think maybe the pigs
put that night here we have hate to
nobody cares nobody cares friggin
awesome I love the style here as well it
reminds me of um God I can't put my
finger on it but like maybe like
Scribblenauts like art style like Oh
nuts
I kind of see the Psychonauts oh yeah
tim schafer game or a double fun game
from yeah 2005 whatever that came out
for sure but yeah this looks great
I love the kind of like the crazy eyed I
know skunk at that's really awesome like
the grain beer - he just looks like this
is like an old man crazy arty yeah for
sure
nobody cares so good so the I did see
this yeah so this is obviously not art
or in-game apparently was it Hannah
I believe her Hannah a bookshelf girl
hook shelf girl went to Paris Disneyland
and saw this I guess you call a display
of like a cowboy or like a like the idea
of like the French it's like a French
interpretation yeah already already for
that matter yeah but it's a little
creepy too and I love that a creepy yeah
it looks like like the top teeth looked
perfect but it looks like who's missing
some bottom teeth I was like this looks
like Arthur just like inevitable
crackhead phase like it's that it's
bound to happen it just don't know when
for sure holy cow that is a pile of
bodies no right
yes that's why he's the executioner I
get it now it's just a day's work right
here Oh golly
Leon Leon vide Leon vide I can't say
these names yeah I'm you know there's a
little bit of calmness to this photo
which is surprising because I feel like
the entire country would be click
attacking you right now but they had a
lot of bodies I almost and like look at
his vest like I almost imagine him
having like a little cup of tea nice
warm cup of tea he's drinking all these
bodies are piled high yeah that's one
that did it for me the Ranger laterally
yeah that is such an awesome classic
burning a stagecoach
one of our dirty Artie's favorite
pastimes indeed very awesome thank you
for the immense P now speaking of bodies
wow that's a lot of policemen that is a
lot of policemen it looks like maybe one
I don't know one random like red vested
I don't know who knows this looks like
it's the barn sound too near right yeah
yeah it looks like it it's gotta because
it's got that like that entryway and
that corner but I'm reading no store in
Anne's burg a $1 for a whiskey in San
Danny bad music and roads then a jackass
saying there's no real men and it's
really good RTR too brutal play yeah
that we live up to the name I'd say
indeed what
please don't ask questions I don't even
know a lot of questions I know I don't
even think I didn't know that you could
grab naked people and they didn't know
there were naked people and occasionally
don't you see a naked guy running
through the forest do you yeah there's a
guy like running around with the wolves
in the forest and there's the making out
of lambs yeah occasionally I've run
across them I'll be like
my horse and I'll hear like oh oh like
that doesn't sound like a wolf and then
they'll be like a naked guy sprinting
through the forest that's hilarious I
did not know that was in the game
awesome that was also from RDR too
brutal play but I've got questions
questions I had to grab it because wow
this the theme of this compilation of
photos is definitely stack bodies as
high as you can honestly this is
ridiculous I was like he's got like the
news cap or whatever yeah my god
yep what am I looking at Tony Peters and
yeah we got ourselves some history here
we have a live record you know Pegasus
is I don't remember Pegasus so far him
is a man it's his interpretation we have
uh we have Butthead already ice on his
cheeks got a plate of spaghetti lot lots
of beans and RPG I wish there's an RPG
in this game but there isn't crocodile
we got the guy the shore the shop clerk
who we killed who was giving his life
advice where is he I don't see him oh
he's down yeah I like also Dutch is
playing getti
Oh spaghetti I got a plan Arthur oh my
god I love it so uh
trilla t'n I'm pronouncing your name
correctly as it says my son made this
for you guys and that's amazing that's
pretty cool
where's my be very cute very awesome
that is awesome tell him thank you for
making that it's amazing yeah we love it
that's all
that's it there's some really good ones
this week I didn't see a lot of them cuz
I was gone or I didn't I didn't check
the hashtag this week yeah it's always a
delight to do that so please continue
sending them in and that is gonna do it
for this
after chapter 20 it's also gonna do it
for season 2 next week we won't have a
full episode but we'll have a highlight
reel of season 2 all right Jake
yes but do stay tuned for more dirty
arty down the road
[Music]